snapchat
spotlight a million
dollars per day paid
to creators
probably the coolest news
so far this year
snapchat released spotlights in november
of 2020 but it is
really just now surfacing and
such an incredible innovation
for inclusive stakeholding for inclusive
equity for creators ultimately the
platforms that
serve the creators the most
especially inclusively with tokens
with equity with ownership with
financial incentives and rewards those
are going to be the platforms that
win and so
of course you see this increase
in the share price from twenty dollars a
share in august of 2020 to now in
february of 2021 it's up to
60 dollars per share
here you can see over here in august
it's at 20 a share
and then it jumps up to about 30 or so
in october but then boom right when it's
publishing
the spotlights it's going up 2x
and now up to 3x
and that's huge and it's only going to
continue
increasing going forward
if it does
this innovation with a high degree
of efficacy and true service to the
creator community
and it depends on how long it's going to
take tick tock
and instagram reels and even youtube
and twitter etc to figure out how to
compete like this
twitter is trying to compete with
twitter spaces with clubhouse
which has its own unique
feature in the media space but there's
nothing quite that is as cool and
financially
incentivized for creators to
make cool content that then gets
rewarded like
this this is it
it's all about inclusive stakeholding
it's all about
inclusive equity that means that the
creators themselves are gaining a stake
they're gaining equity in the success of
their creations they're getting
financial rewards which
is huge now downstream there might be
things like snapchat
actually delivering tokens of ownership
to the creator community as well
which would be massive and so
the platforms that identify
these key innovations around inclusive
stakeholding inclusive
equity financial incentives goal
congruence that's aligned
where if you think about the example
with amazon
when you call the customer service at
amazon boom
immediately you have someone on the
phone boom immediately
they're helping you solve your problem
and boom in a couple minutes you're off
the phone
best customer service around now as a
creator on the youtube platform
when you have an issue on the youtube
platform zero percent
chance unless you're in the 10 million
plus subscriber mark
will you actually be able to contact
anybody
the maybe half a percent chance is if
you email the creator support team
a dozen times and then maybe you get
half a percent chance that they'll reply
to you if you have
under especially a hundred thousand
subscribers
and so tick tock is similarly we've had
connor sherry on the show who had almost
a million followers
on tick tock and that he could not get
in touch
with tick tock when they began
throttling
and shadow banning his content
and making it so that he couldn't go as
viral anymore
and that similar problems are occurring
across social platforms the vast
majority of them
where you can't actually get a hold of
anybody that works at the company to
solve the problem that you want
to accomplish getting solved so
the future for creators is especially if
snapchat along with the innovation with
this purse that then becomes shared
every single day that if you
add to that the beautiful
relationship from somebody that works at
snapchat
with these creators that are succeeding
on the platform
if you create a better
relationship between the medium and
those that engineer and design the
medium with the creators that create on
it
boom it's game over that's the way to
win
these massive social media wars that are
happening
in the attention economy
the pie in terms of the amount of
hours of waking human attention
is limited there's about 120
billion or so hours of waking human
attention per day because people
are awake about 16 hours a day and sleep
the other eight and there's eight
billion or so humans
and what's happening is that
the social media platforms are in a
competition
for our attention because they want us
to be on their platform so they can make
the advertising revenue
so that they can raise their stock price
and that's why you have
the instagram reels that immediately
copied the tick tock phenomenon that was
happening
and that's why now snapchat spotlight is
not only copying that
but also saying [ __ ] we're gonna make a
[ __ ]
purse a daily one million dollar purse
for the top
creators on the platform and we're gonna
pay them out within a month
and so we'll get to that in more detail
here in a bit this is the key
paying out creators ultimately it's
about what is going to make creators the
happiest
what is the most inclusive stakeholding
again this is compet competing with tick
tock
and instagram reels snapchat has
250 million daily active users dau
i would not be surprised if that number
went
up by a hundred million within even just
the next couple of months of people
around the planet
that are getting a whiff of these big
purses that they can potentially
gain access to daily
so we're going to show a demo of this as
well on the device
and so the general
payout works this way daily
approximately the top 100 or so creators
with the most popularly viewed
spotlights
are going to get paid a range from
anywhere from if you're the number one
spotlight of that
day if you have over a million views on
your spotlight and the algorithm works a
lot like
tick tocks does so if you watch the
spotlight
and if you watch it all the way through
and it loops
to the beginning again and you keep
watching it
then it's going the algorithm is going
to send that
spotlight video into more people's
cues that are on the spotlight
feed that's generally how the algorithm
works
and so that's why people are starting to
realize that when they make these tick
tocks and when they make these
instagram reels and when they make the
snapchat spotlights what they're trying
to do is they're trying to
put a unique gem inside of it
that then makes people want to watch it
again and maybe even
pause it and analyze it and even
in tick tiktok you can like and share it
but there's no liking and sharing on the
snapchat
spotlights yet and that's really
interesting that phenomenon
and we'll see sort of where that goes
but so there's a
a spectrum of getting paid where
approximately a hundred thousand dollars
for the number one slot where you get
maybe over a million views
and then if you're in the number 100
slot at the bottom you get paid the
least maybe about a thousand dollars
can you imagine just making a snapchat
spotlight
and getting a thousand dollars after a
month
of going through the verification
process and whatnot
and so this is what is really exciting
for people
now you can only submit every five
minutes
to the snapchat spotlight so people are
submitting
somewhere around 100 times a day if
they're
really going hardcore at it because i
believe the max you can submit is 192
times a day
if you sleep eight hours we'll get to
that also in a bit
so this means that snapchat is spending
365 million dollars per year
which is nothing that is literally chump
change
that's literally nothing if you think
about it that means it's like a billion
dollars every three years that they're
spending
and that means that if snapchat did this
for
a hundred years they would only spend
like 35 billion dollars that's nothing
for a hundred years to spend 35 billion
dollars which is like a third of the net
worth of elon musk or jeff bezos
that's a hilarious joke
because
you can imagine that they're going to be
grossing way more than 365 million
dollars per year from advertising
so snapchat is making way more than a
million dollars per
day in ad revenue and then what they're
doing is they're just distributing that
back to creators
and this is very much like the uber
approach of bulldozing to domination
where you say we're going to just like
uber did
go to every single city and just begin
going
absolutely bonkers taking over the taxi
cab industries
not even asking for permission from the
cities etc
and not even turning a profit just to be
able to get us to the place where
everybody uses the app
where everybody is getting ready for the
autonomous
vehicle era and to have uh
uber step up as the main competitor
there
and potentially we'll see what happens
with tesla
because as their artificial intelligence
within their autonomous vehicles
is more successful right now that
they may take a larger market share
actually
in the autonomous ride sharing industry
than even uber does
but snapchat in very many ways is
reminding me
of the style of bulldozing from 2012
onward that uber did
so if snapchat doubles and triples down
on the innovation and the relationship
with the creators here
and beats out tick tock and beats out
instagram reels and just dominates the
space and gets creators paid out fast
and creates a really strong support
communication with creators
man this is gonna be some straight
bulldozing to domination
because this is the absolute future is
this style of payout
to creators because it creates that
mutual
synergistic goal congruence
the financial reward incentive is there
it's aligned that's the winning piece
that's the winning piece tick tock kind
of brushes creators off
right now in many ways instagram
also aka facebook and even youtube
in many ways as well nobody has
this relationship yet set up with
creators like snapchat is beginning to
do
if they crush this they're gonna crush
the long game
okay so we can go ahead and do a small
demo here as well to kind of show you
guys what we're talking about
all right so what you see here is you
see the general
snapchat screen
and then if you click on in the bottom
right corner
this play button it's going to send you
to the spotlight and you begin watching
the spotlight videos
and so so now we just watch that one
again
and it's the same style functionality
where you scroll
up and then you see that happening now
if you want to and see
you know stuff like that these great
human achievements that one was really
really really fast so now if you click
on
this top spotlight snaps right here
what happens is look at this this video
that somebody took of their dog at an
aquarium slash
zoo where a dolphin was
if we can go back to that where a
dolphin was playing with a dog like this
earned this person 2 000
dollars just for taking that video
this guy i've watched this before he
cuts down this tree
and he makes four thousand dollars from
a video of him cutting down the tree
this is the guy that's also really
popular on tick tock he's the guy that's
doing these like athletic feats where
he's trying to throw the paper towel
or the toilet paper onto that and so
he's making three
thousand five hundred dollars from that
and there's there's more there's this
game that's played for 2 000 bucks with
pops there's this guy doing
really incredible hockey
tricks scoring goals very accurately
and so there's all of this sort of
crazy multi thousand dollar winnings
and stuff and so it's just nuts so you
can go and watch those stories
and then you can also submit right so if
you go here
and then if you go like something like
hey guys we're currently literally
streaming
to youtube talking about how cool
snapchat spotlights are and how creators
are earning a million dollars a day
it's so dope and we are so grateful for
this inclusive equity opportunity
and boom so you know you have that video
and then
you go so i'm gonna save that video and
then i'm just gonna click this button
send to and then from here all you have
to do is click
spotlight at the top and then you can
add a topic
and say you know snapchat
and then you can add another topic and
you can say
spotlight
and you can say creator
and so now you just click done there's
all your topics up there
there's your spotlight and now you just
click this
bottom button the bottom right corner
and now
what happens is you go to your profile
and in your profile
you can see this spotlight and snap
map where you can now observe
how well your see up there in the top
right corner you can see my snap status
is submitted
and we can re-listen to it also we can
turn the
maybe we can turn the volume up
and i'm not sure if it's just because
i'm using the the feature where i'm
showcasing my phone screen on the
computer and into the stream
but there you go so that's a little bit
of an idea of how this is working
and just so you guys have an idea of
that
all right and then now if that spotlight
video that we submitted
if it rakes in a million plus views
it'll pay me out a hundred thousand
dollars or so
that would mean each view was worth
approximately 10 cents but that's only
if the viewer was to only watch one
video which is highly unlikely
so it's if they got on and they watched
it and they gave me a view count and
then they got off right away
which is very highly unlikely
and there's going to be a lot more
competition
as more people on board and it'll become
harder to win the daily prize money
so each viewer is likely watching dozens
of minutes of videos not just
one and so they're likely creating a
dollar
plus of revenue for snapchat since they
are watching
several ads while browsing so if you're
browsing on snapchat
for several dozens of minutes what's
happening is you're
ingesting the advertisements that are
built in and they
are selling that advertising space to
different companies
for pennies if not nickels and dimes and
so you're contributing
potentially dollars to snapchat
as they're selling that advertising
space and then what they're doing
is when you watch the view the video
that's contributing to the purse of the
daily one million dollars
and then they are distributing that to
the top
viewed creators on the spotlights page
every single day it's as simple as that
and so again when you look at the
numbers over at around 250 million daily
active users daus
some users won't earn snapchat a penny
in ads because all they'll do is they'll
log in
they'll reply to a couple dms maybe
watch a video and leave
but other users will earn snapchat ten
dollars in ads because they'll use the
platform for five
hours that day and so you have to
recognize there's this big spectrum
of snapchat use cases from using it all
day
every day and giving them 10 plus
dollars a day
versus people that barely give them five
cents every single day that is
contributing to that purse
and so cam casey is this 19 year old
tick talker with seven plus million
followers
and i heard him first discuss the
snapchat spotlights
on david dobrik and jason nash's views
podcast
and that's a really good podcast and
actually david dobrik and the vlog squad
in general
are some of the most creative people
in the sitcom vlog space and just
in general that have figured out how to
be entertaining and also be authentic
and be fun and be playful
and communicate that via video to
inspire other people
and so they had a great conversation on
the views podcast about it
where casey reported in mid
january to be making 3
million plus dollars since spotlight
launched in november 2020. literally
in two plus months maybe two two and a
half months
he has made over a million dollars a
month
that is [ __ ] insane so
that speaks to both how few people know
about spotlight
right now but also to how much he's
learning
algorithmically how to create optimal
content that then
makes it so that he's more likely to
trend on that spotlights page
and so the more creative you are the
more likely
you're going to keep people that loop on
the video
and have the algorithm branch your video
out to more people
and trend and then get your ability to
get a thousand dollar or even ten
thousand or hundred thousand dollar
purse
and you can post about a hundred plus
times per day
that's a lot but then because
one every five minutes that means up to
12
per hour which means a maximum of 192
per day with eight hours of sleep these
are basically lottery ticket submissions
but the more creative you are the more
likely you are to win those lottery
tickets
so it's got the creative edge to it
and so here's what you have to do you
have to go through this process of
taking about three to four weeks
after snapchat pay verification to
receive the money
and what happens is if you trend and you
get into the top 100
team snapchat will send you a chat
message notifying you
and then you have to go and confirm your
email your
age and your taxpayer verification via
hyper wallet which paypal bought
two years ago for some 400 million
dollars or so
and then this is sort of what that looks
like
here i'm reading the spotlight terms and
conditions
and i actually heard from somebody this
is actually a really good point that
we're bringing this up
i heard from somebody that the
that the reason why some of these videos
like this one right here if you see it
has the tick tock
water mark this was a video that i
posted
to tick tock about entheogens and about
the
specifically the incredible benefits
of psilocybin
and what happened was was that
if this this got over 500 thousand views
on tick tock
but because it has the watermark on it i
heard that
snapchat will not allow the
videos that have watermarks on them onto
spotlight
so basically what i'm gonna have to do
is i'm gonna have to recreate
that video on snapchat spotlights as
well
and so that's an interesting thing is
that
for the platforms that watermark the
videos because i'm pretty sure instagram
reels does not watermark the videos
and i'm not sure if snapchat does yet
but you can then redistribute that video
if it's not watermarked across platforms
but i also heard from connor sherry that
algorithmically
that on tiktok if you record in the app
you actually have a higher propensity to
trend than if you record outside of the
app and then upload
into the app which i thought was very
interesting as well
and this might even be the section
spotlights
are created solely by you and do not
misappropriate any third party rights
including
copyright and there's your trademark
right there boom trademark
and so that's part of the equation
and then there's the revenue terms and
services that we were looking at as well
and then there's just this guy there's
just this general spotlight guidelines
faq
as well how do you determine who earns
the shares of the
one million dollars and so you just have
to go
and read these things and try and
understand that i've done a good job
at parsing and synthesizing and
distilling for you but you have to go
and do your own research and you have to
go and do
the trial and error process that's what
biology and
adaptation and fitness is all about is
how quickly can you hear
snapchat spotlights is offering a one
million dollar
daily prize to creators and
if you know anything about biological
fitness and adaptation the first thing
you think of is
holy [ __ ] i'm gonna go learn everything
about that
immediately and go and begin trial and
error publishing creative content
so that i can earn some of these one
thousand dollar ten thousand dollar
higher purses
and then be able to fuel that into all
the other creative
endeavors that i'm doing but there is a
balance between
that and also the ability to
simultaneously
slow down and turn inward and be aware
of your awareness
itself and recognize that awareness is
shared and that it's eternal and this is
just
one creation design this is just one
expression
one dream and that
the more that you god realize that you
go inward towards that infinite towards
that eternity towards that ineffable
absolute
that it makes it so that you can ebb and
flow more
easily between these insane daily one
million dollar purses that occur
and also between the ability to just
slow
down and to just go and bake in the sun
for 10 minutes and stretch your body and
know how to breathe
and that's the balance of the inward
with the outward
and that's what this is all about that's
what all of this infinity expressing
itself is all about
so it takes about three to four weeks to
get paid
now this is crazy because you'll have
things like this 27 year old lowe's
employee
who was earning 12 and 50 cents per hour
who posted her sister deep frying
a turkey on thanksgiving and she
earned five hundred
thousand dollars on snapchat spotlight
what deep frying a turkey on
thanksgiving just capturing a little
15 second video posting at the spotlight
and then just getting a message from
snapchat and it's like
yo dawg you got millions of views and
you got the largest purse
so far 500k it's like
what oh my goodness
so we'll see what happens moving forward
because that was back in november and so
now in
february things have likely changed a
lot where you might even have
you know 50 million more people that are
aware of this now that are posting into
spotlights trying to get these purses
so fascinating so
the algorithmically curated feed of
vertical
video is so fascinating
it really only hit truly
maybe around 2019 or something
because musically was kind of poppin
but not enough to where the planet
became aware of it
in 2019 though tick tock
[ __ ] took over everybody started
becoming aware of tick
tock
and that's what made this idea of the
vertical
video whereas youtube and all the other
platforms have been horizontal video
it really popularized vertical video
and the algorithmically curated for you
feed right the for you page right
and that's why instagram reels boop
copied it right away snapchat spotlight
boop copied it right away
even youtube has stories now right
twitter has stories
facebook has stories all these platforms
have stories now
everybody's copying stories and soon
people are going to be copying these
creator purses because they recognize
that the only way to win
as a media giant moving forward is to
create an inclusive
goal congruence with your creators and
that financial
incentive that makes them create content
on your platform
and we have to be really smart about how
artificial intelligence is playing its
role
in this process because
it may also be a good idea to figure out
how to
create the business plan at
the major tech companies that are in the
media space
so that it's not tied to the advertisers
so it's not like snapchat is tied to
getting 500 million dollars of
advertising revenue per year
or more so that it can then fund the 1
million daily purses of creators
but rather if today
i was asked hey will you pay five
dollars
into snapchat every single month
yeah probably and what's interesting
about that is
then you create this pool that then
people can create and draw from and they
don't even have to see
advertisements and by the way there's
so many ultra high net worth people
around the planet 225
000 people around the planet have more
than 30 million dollars in
assets us dollars
and to them they can contribute a
hundred dollars a month or even a
thousand dollars a month without a
problem for people that can't contribute
on a monthly basis
as a subscription and so what happens is
then you have these platfor you have
these
ultra high net worth people that
contribute their finances to these
media platforms that then make it so
that we don't have to see
advertisements so that we don't have
these perverse incentives with the
business plans
and then you have some of this next
point where
with the trending dancing videos prank
videos challenges tutorials education
science spirituality which is really
what we're about on the platform
and there's none of these public like
counts or comments
and you noticed that when you were on
the platform is that there was no
there was no public there was no public
like
count that's what i was
getting at earlier is that
there's no
here look in the bottom right corner all
you see is the heart
but you don't actually see the amount of
likes that it has
which is super fascinating there's no
amount of likes
a lot different than tick tock which
shows you that the person has five likes
versus that they have
five million likes on the video
super interesting
and so
and so now this leads me to the next
point which is that within this
correction of the perverse incentives
around the business plans and having
potentially these high net worth people
that contribute a thousand dollars per
month which they are literally trying to
find trusted places to put
money to maximize human potential
where all creators and not just
influencers make money when these videos
go viral which is huge
somebody with literally zero followers
that goes
viral on the platform like on tick tock
if somebody
got five million views on their video on
tick tock
and they had no followers before that
tick tock keeps all of the advertising
revenue
whereas now that person is going to get
ten thousand dollars from the daily
purse
which is [ __ ] crazy that is beautiful
that's so genius
and so what this is enabling to do is
it's enabling the crowd sourcing of the
planet's top creative talent
around specifically the ability to
compress a unique story into a 15 second
video
and publish that and captivate people's
attention so now what you can do is you
can
find like snapchat's going to have this
record they already do from november
until february they have four months
of the daily top 100 creators
and they are now keeping this ledger of
that it's private only they have it
right now
but what we can do is we can potentially
open source that and we can recognize
who are the most creative people on the
planet that are winning this most
frequently
and then we can do things like enter
them into these america's got talent
style competitions as a planet and
crowdsource
creativity at a deeper level so imagine
like the top 10 creators
that have been doing this over the last
four months and earning the most money
maybe they form a writing team and a
production team
that work together with another indie
studio or maybe with netflix one of the
bigger studios
and they produce an animated series
around something really fascinating
entertaining thought provoking as well
there's many different ways to do this
and so the ultra high net worth people
if they correct the perverse incentives
in these business plans and help fuel
these purses
what will happen is that they can
potentially also get involved
in the the benefits like with the giving
pledge you get this kind of stamp of
approval that you've
decided that you're going to give more
than 50 or more than 90
or even 99 of your billions of dollars
away
and that to maximize human potential and
in this case
you can maybe get the stamp of approval
for the ultra high net worth people
and say that they're actually
contributing
to the
the separation of the
business plan from the
perverse incentives with the advertising
industry
and that way we can take our attention
back
and we can maximize the creativity
and so they can get the little stamp of
approval for that
process which is beautiful and this is
in
very many ways like a massive
decentralization renaissance
again this crowdsourcing of the planet's
top talent there's a reason why there's
two
[ __ ] big ass stars there because it's
the coolest [ __ ] [ __ ] about this
along with these creator purses that
daily happen
this crowd sourcing of the planet's top
talent is
mwah it's beautiful and that we should
open source that ledger of the daily top
100
and then accumulate the points and then
put
people into even more cool competitions
and collaborations and play and this
type of stuff
so snapchat can become the key player if
it moves fast because tick tock will
compete with these 1 million
daily purses fast and so will instagram
reels if it's smart and even youtube
will
the clubhouse twitter space conversation
is nowhere near as interesting as the
inclusive equity opportunity
with creators on snapchat spotlight this
is the decentralization renaissance
it is no longer just the
media platforms that have an asymmetric
relationship with the creators but now
the creators are being offered these
purses
and there's a more symmetric more
harmonious relationship now
love it and it's crazy i was looking at
this
snapchat is also incorporating astrology
into the platform i was so surprised
when i saw this
you go here and you click on this little
button that's
right below your name and boom
like i'm a libra and it's just
interesting
because you never like
you would never think that youtube or
twitter or
instagram or any of these other
platforms would be like
hey what day were you born where were
you born and what time were you born and
let's figure out your astrology as well
and so it's a very interesting sort of
um
like spiritually synthesis
with science and technology and
engineering
and artificial intelligence is to also
recognize the beauty
of taking the ancient spiritual wisdoms
from across the planet which is that
your
celestial bodies of all sorts the moon
the star the especially jupiter saturn
these massive planets
that they have a good amount to do with
us energetically they just do
you can't say that they don't you can
see
the way that the moon affects planet
earth you can see that the way that the
sun
affects planet earth everything has an
energetic effect on the planet
and so now we're using science to probe
in to
what spiritually speaking we've been
talking about for millennial which is so
fascinating
and there's also a whole suite of other
fascinating
features that snapchat has with
geo-location features
man these are so interesting i don't
even know where
where i've been i have not seen this but
you go to you go to i think
my friends nope you go to
you go to this button the bottom left
button that's right
so you go to this bottom left button and
boom what
are you kidding me look at this i had no
idea that snapchat
had incorporated this feature where
you're like yo
my friends are like hey i'm in kansas
city right now
i'm in denver right now i'm in mexico
city right now i'm in vancouver etc
and you can just go and zoom in and
click in on them
and you can do these little heat map
things like i can go to vegas i don't
have any of my friends there
but i can click in on vegas and boom i'm
now i'm watching
what's trending in that area
you know so so snapchat is not [ __ ]
around at all they've done a lot of
really
interesting features and i don't know if
you guys have seen their
i don't know if you guys have seen um
they have a bunch of media packages that
they're offering here
you can kind of see that here as well
when you go to
look in in this discover section
right there's a snap original ryan
doesn't know there's one right there so
there's a snapchat original
and then there's this one called hooks
and phenoms
and this is life and bodytalk and hot
take and esquire
and there's all this type of stuff where
a bitmoji stories and so there's all
these little like
stories and there's
these little media packages and that has
a lot to do also with
um with the relationship of the
financial advertisers and also with
packaging these
shows that are on snapchat only which is
something unique as well just like
spotify
was swooping up joe rogan and many of
these other
performers is that to exclusivity
snapchat's also trying to be exclusive
i thought it was fascinating that quibby
died
i thought that quibby was going to
become a performer
in the media space but they launched
during covet and that had its own
difficulties and whatnot
but also if you haven't seen snapchat's
snapchat ar glasses
i don't know if you guys have seen these
yet but
snapchat has these really interesting um
augmented reality glasses where it's
both
a it's both like the capturing of
a video through just like the click of a
button and boom it's capturing your 15
second video
but also there's an augmented reality
feature on them as well
and so it's very much like trying to
mirror a more
a kind of a less sophisticated and less
computationally intensive process than
microsoft's hololens is and so
it's interesting and i don't think
they're that expensive either i think
they're just
like a couple hundred dollars and it
looks like snapchat teamed up with gucci
on these limited edition ones and all
this type of stuff
and so they have a lot going for them
interestingly enough i knew about the ar
glasses but i didn't actually know about
those geolocation features yet
and so this is in general just a huge
rebirth for snapchat
it's a brilliant inclusive equity
pioneering that they're doing
and their stunk is likely going to soar
and
for those that don't know stonk is a
playful
meme uh on stock
and so their stonk is going to soar this
is a brilliant inclusive equity
pioneering that they're doing
a huge rebirth for them
sourcing the planet's top talent is so
interesting
this is a huge part of the
decentralization renaissance
it's pretty quick right now it's about a
month or so to get paid
again people reporting making three
million dollars over just
four months or so watch that number of
250 million daily active users increase
watch the tick tock and instagram reels
come in as competitors with purses as
well this is huge for planetary
inclusive stakeholding and inclusive
equity and gold congruence
and the relationship of these platforms
with their creators it's just huge
and also be ready because this
is for sure going to continue increasing
if snapchat doubles down and
innovates faster on this than anybody
else does and if they have the best
relationship with their creators
period because it's all
about
what is going to make the creators most
happy
and that's this it's inclusive equity
it's inclusive stakeholding
it's goal congruence financial incentive
and alignment with creators
it's that simple the idea of paying
creators out
a million dollars a day in a purse for
creating the best spotlight videos mwah
genius
genius it's perfect and to slowly move
away from the perverse
incentives around the advertising on the
attention economy
towards the solutions that we provided
during the episode
ultra high net worth people can come in
and fuel this for
a thousand bucks a month which is chump
change to them
and they can get the stamp of
contributing to this
world top tier community of
talent and we can get away from the
perverse
incentives around the advertising at the
same time
so i hope you enjoyed
this breakdown of the future of these
media platforms and their relationship
with the creators
and if it brought you value i would love
for you to like the video and subscribe
if you haven't
please it helps us so much leave a
comment below with your thoughts
love to hear from you also
share the video with other people
especially so that more people become
aware of this one million dollar per day
purse
and go and create on the platform
leverage your biological fitness and
adaptation
to go and play with it submit a several
times per day
onto it and see what you can do with
trying to
get a purse a thousand bucks ten
thousand bucks how exciting is that
again a simple video of a turkey being
fried
got five hundred thousand dollars back
in november but still
and remember to balance
that inward the god realization
the realization of eternity of infinity
with the outward expression that is
artistic
in this finite dreamed creation design
expression
learn how to balance those two out
harmonically
because that is the nature of reality go
all the way in
to your true metaphysical nature so that
effortlessly you can express yourself
artistically outward
adore you infinitely thank you for
tuning in
infinite love adore you thank you
may we live long and prosper
you